[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
because
oh
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please wear a mask
if you need a face mask
please let staff member know thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
oh
um
[Music]
[Applause]
all businesses
[Music]
i don't
[Music]
has been too strong
[Applause]
now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
a soldier
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
sisters
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
so
there's
[Music]
that's okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
i yeah
[Music]
thank
[Music]
oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
congressman thanks
vice president
[Applause]
some special guests here with us today i
don't know about you
but in 12 days i can't wait
to send nancy pelosi back to san
francisco
[Music]
i can't wait till she's gone in
retirement i would never have to deal
with her again
[Applause]
[Music]
i i have met a lot of incredible men
and women who i've had the pleasure and
honor of serving with in the congress
over
the last four years and at the top of my
list
all the way from the state of louisiana
is the republican
with steve scalise
ladies and gentlemen there are few
people if anyone at all
who works as hard as steve scalise does
to help republicans win
all over the country and i'm so proud to
have you here with us tonight
steve scalise is a man of faith he's a
man of integrity he's a
conservative fighter he fights her
conservative values
in the house of representatives i got to
tell you when i got to congress
i wanted to be like steve scalise right
he's the kind of guy that i want to be
like just like i want to be
like mike pence these are men of
integrity and conservative values now
they have something encountered
they both were a chair of something
called the republican
study committee which is the
conservative caucus and conference
within the republican party
and i'm proud to tell you here tonight
your congressman
is going to be the next chairman
following in their footsteps of the same
conservative group
[Applause]
when i'm chairman of the republican
study committee fighting for our
conservative values
on your behalf steve scalise is going to
be
the majority leader of the republican
party in the united states
ladies and gentlemen for the third year
in a row i'm proud to have
my great friend a mentor someone who i
look up to so much
steve scalise right here in fort wayne
indiana campaigning for me
welcome steve scalise
[Music]
again as we're just 12 days away from
the most consequential
election in the history of this country
maybe since
maybe since abraham lincoln think about
what's at stake you know what's at stake
how great is it to be a hoosier you've
got the vice president of the united
states right here from indiana
[Applause]
you've got a great congressman in jim
banks
he's going to be the next great chairman
of the republican
study committee
[Applause]
you've got people all around the country
who cannot wait
to show up in person and vote on
november 3rd to re-elect
donald trump and mike
[Music]
and his gym to fire nancy pelosi
because we both share something in
common we might have a little bit of a
rivalry
louisiana and indiana
the girl who went to the same middle
school is both of my kids
harrison and madison saint catherine of
siena
is the school where amy coney barrett
the next supreme court
justice
[Music]
she's got a unanimous vote today
and that shows you the values of this
president this is a president
who says what he's going to do and then
he does what he says
on the supreme court he did it once he
did it twice
and now he's going to do it a third time
[Applause]
president trump said he could keep
america safe he said he was going to
build the wall he's building
the wall he's protecting this country he
said he would take on
countries like china who were cheating
and stealing
and not following the rules of trade
deals and he's been standing up
to china and will continue
when he was in the white house with
barack obama to stand up to china did he
do it
when joe biden was sitting over one of
the worst economies we had
ever seen when donald trump came into
office donald trump promised
he was going to cut our taxes and
rebuild our country so we could make
america great again did donald trump
keep his words
on is that he'd repeal the trump tax
cuts
well guess what i don't know if joe read
the bill i read it he'll pass that bill
that don't cut taxes for every income
level in america
and if you repeal it that means joe
biden will raise taxes on every
income level in america we let that
happen
no way joe biden's tax increases
would put three to four thousand dollars
more burden on the backs of families
in indiana that's what's at stake joe
biden stood on the stage in the last
debate by the way
how great did mike pence do with that
and standing up for the great work that
this administration has done to get this
country back on track
to build the economy back to get us to
the point where they're not one
not two not three but four
internationally respected companies
on the verge of an approved vaccine by
the fda against 19.
that's what this president has done
a lot of things he said that
unfortunately his record doesn't back up
he said he doesn't support the green new
deal
i've read the brand new deal i think you
know what it means the green indeed
wants to give us back in the paris
accord
the paris accord is french for the green
new deal that's what they would do to
raise your electricity rates to make it
impossible to manufacture things you
make a lot of things in indiana
good luck trying to do that and they've
got the green new deal but mine said
don't worry he's not for it
except there's one problem then we went
and looked at his website the next date
it's still on his website
you know you can't say one thing and do
the other you can't say don't worry your
taxes won't work
except he's going to repeal the trump
tax cuts which means your taxes will go
up
he can't say he's not freaky funding the
police when he's on video
joe biden on video saying that he will
redirect money
away from police there's no difference
if you're redirecting money away from
somebody you're defunding now
we will not let them defund the police
[Applause]
of the men and women in uniform they
saved
my life
of our men and women in law enforcement
and they did the same thing for our
young women in uniform
during the five years go look this up
joe biden was talking about the military
except one thing
when joe biden was in the white house
our men and women in uniform
were dying more in training missions
than in combat and i'm not talking about
a close margin
if you were a men and women serving in
our military during the five
years you had a five times higher chance
of dying training in america to be in
the military
they're going to iraq or afghanistan
because they didn't give our men and
women in uniform the tools they need
donald trump and mike pence said we're
going to fix that and they reversed it
they properly funded our military they
gave a much-needed pay raise
to our military you don't see those
training deaths anymore
[Applause]
a guy i got to serve with in the house
for five years
one of the most upstanding respected
people in the house then went on
to be a great governor of the great
state of indiana and now he's doing our
country proud as the vice president
you're going to hear from mike pence and
he's going to be talking to you about
what's at stake as well
and i think you know what you're going
to be doing on november 3rd but you know
what i guess
each of you has a few friends that maybe
don't know where they're going to be
they don't know what they're going to
how they're gonna vote it's so important
that we let them know what's at stake
when they talk about getting in the
paris support it would wreck
america's economy do you know there's
not one country in europe in compliance
with the paris support not even france
where paris is located
because it wrecks your economy it's
unachievable and it doesn't make any
sense we're reducing carbon emissions in
america
not by wrecking our economy but through
american ingenuity
but if you send those jobs to china
because guess what china's in compliance
you know why because they've exempted
china from the paris court which joe
biden wants to get back in
china would love the paris support
because they would just send more of our
jobs back to china we cannot
let that happen let's not wreck our
manufactured economy
let's keep america great as the vice
president said
make america great again again we
need to look there's so much momentum i
was just in pennsylvania yesterday
i started in scranton pennsylvania i
could not find anybody that said
that joe biden is their hometown guy
there was so much
support for donald trump and mike pence
you saw the polls four years ago those
are the same polls you see today where
they said
oh they can't win here they can't win
michigan they can't win wisconsin
and what happened four years ago they
won wisconsin they won michigan
they won they won indiana they're going
to win it again
it's going to take your support your
energy i want this excitement
let's keep this going keep the momentum
and keep america great thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
governor of the great state of indiana
governor eric holcomb
why don't you uh why don't you
pretend that the vice president of the
united states of america can hear you
and let him know how you think he did in
the debate
[Applause]
with you as my witness i want to
i want the vice president to be reminded
he calls in he checks in from time to
time about how we're doing all around
the state of indiana
but i want to assure him
that we are on a roll in the state of
indiana and the state of indiana is
going to be first
on the board come election night
[Applause]
in the last four years we were on a roll
in 2016 and since then
we have set an all-time high new jobs
record we have set an all-time high new
wage record we have set an all-time high
new capital investment record we tripled
our foreign direct
investment in the state of indiana folks
where i come from that's called
onshoring
we're doing it in a record fashion
the state indiana
one in the nation for our infrastructure
we take care of that's paid for not debt
finance
at the very same time that we've been on
this roll
attracting investment from all over the
world all over the country coming to
indiana our phone is ringing off the
hook there are folks making bad
decisions around this country
and we're creating real separation
between us and the competition
at the very same time don't lose sight
of this the state of indiana
was just announced about 10 days ago has
become the number one
state in america for foster kids getting
[Applause]
adopted
since we started keeping score and
recording it
it goes all the way back to
you're 1900 it in community after
community
and every step of the way
our very own the former my predecessor
the former
governor of the state of indiana and now
america's vice president
has been helping us every step of the
way
for the time they came right out of the
gate and cut as steve scalise has said
burdensome regulations on our families
cut those over
regulated rules that were stifling
business investment
they have helped us for a state like
indiana the number one manufacturing
state
in america a top act state in america
they saw fit to actually not talk about
getting the usmca
modernized they got it done that means
more
hoosier products are being exported
around the world
than
[Applause]
because of their ever
and here's the one thing i want to leave
you with i've known this guy for
decades personally and he is the same
guy from the first day i
met he has not forgot where he came from
he has not forgot the cornfield in his
backyard in columbus
it got into the where he is today and
it's going to get him where he's going
ladies and gentlemen
let's give a warm fort wayne welcome
to the vice president of the united
states of america
mike pence
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
governor holcomb congressman banks
congressman bushon
pastor rick hawks and kathy my fellow
hoosiers
from near and far it is great to be back
home again
and it's great to be back home in the
hoosier state just 12
days away from another great victory all
across
indiana and all across america
well thank you all for coming out and
it's a particular honor to be here
the man you just heard from a few
moments ago he's actually the second
ranking republican in the united states
house of representatives but america
came to know him a few short years ago
after tragedy struck in his life they
saw him as a man of courage
a man of convictions i can tell you he
is one of the most courageous
conservatives in the united states of
america would you join me in thanking
congressman steve scalise
[Applause]
looking around here i'm seeing so many
good friends i'm going to start to get
all choked up
finally it's great to be here with a man
who's literally been a friend of mine
for decades
and i like to say that in 2016 he was
the second most surprised man in indiana
we literally when i got the phone call
to join the national ticket it wasn't
too long
before that that he got a phone call to
join my ticket
and he has simply gone on to be one of
the best
governors in america would you join me
in thanking
governor eric holcomb
so good to be with so many friends and
if you have a chair you can feel free to
take it
but i'm here for one reason and one
reason only
and that is that indiana and america
need four more years of president donald
trump in the white house
[Applause]
and right after you get that done let's
get four more years
of governor eric holcomb in the state
house
[Applause]
you know four years ago here in the
hoosier state and all across this
country
a movement was born it's a movement of
everyday americans from
every walk of life here in indiana
we believe we could be strong again
we believe we could be prosperous again
we said yes to president donald trump in
2016
and i know indiana is going to say yes
to four more years
of president donald trump in 2020.
and let's make indiana first on the
board to re-elect president donald trump
[Applause]
you know the president is in nashville
today
he and i chatted this morning and uh he
headed out for a presidential debate
he is going to take the stage in just a
few hours
and he is going to take the fight
straight to joe biden
and i can't wait
[Music]
[Music]
you know just a few weeks ago we had a
little vice
presidential debate out in salt lake
city utah
[Applause]
some people think we did all right
but i can tell you it was a privilege
for me to be on that stage
to be able to talk about all that we've
accomplished together over the last
three and a half years and what we can
still do
with four more years of president donald
trump in the white house
i mean think about it four years ago we
inherited a military that had been
hollowed out by devastating budget cuts
an economy that was struggling to break
out of the slowest
economy a recovery since the great
depression
terrorism was on the rise around the
world
and we witnessed a steady assault on our
most cherished values
but in three short years
we rebuild our military
we revived our economy we secured
our border supported law enforcement and
stood for
life liberty and the constitution of the
united states
[Music]
it's amazing to think what we
accomplished in those first three years
it all starts of course with our
national defense
you know after years of one budget cut
after another that literally caused
a large portion of our air force to be
kept on the ground the year we took
office
to be used as spare parts to keep other
aircraft in the air
president donald trump signed the
largest
investment in our national defense since
the days of ronald reagan
you know and for me it's personal you
know when we started out in politics
in indiana 20 years ago our our kids
were about the age of your kids jim
they were little our son was six our
daughters were
five and four now our son's a captain in
the united states marine corps
[Applause]
[Music]
and our daughter is married to a navy
pilot
currently deployed
[Applause]
and i'm proud to report on their behalf
as your vice president and as a proud
dad and proud
father-in-law we are finally giving our
soldiers sailors airmen marines
and coast guard the support that they
[Applause]
deserve
and it's not just been about those who
wear the uniform and their families
it's also been about all of you who
served in our military in the course of
your lives
in fact before i go further if uh if
you're able to stand or just raise your
hand if
if you served in the armed forces of the
united states would you
would you just raise your hand and let
us be able to thank you one more time
you for your service
thank you
thank you
you know when joe biden is vice
president you all remember
america saw years of scandal at the va
that shocked the conscience of our
nation
we literally had america's heroic
veterans
dying in waiting lines
waiting for health care at our va
facilities
but when president donald trump walked
into the oval office all that changed
president trump has signed the most
sweeping reforms of the va
in 50 years we fired more than 3 000
employees
that weren't giving our veterans the
care they deserved
and veterans choice is now available for
every veteran in america
[Music]
and none of that would have been
possible without our partners in the
congress
and standing here in his own hometown i
can tell you firsthand
none of that would have been possible
without the extraordinary
leadership of a veteran serving on the
house armed services committee
and the veterans committee would you
join me in thanking congressman jim
banks for being there for our veterans
and our troops
what a great gun so it's been about
providing for the common defense
and being there for our veterans and in
our first three years
after joe biden spent eight years trying
to
spend and tax and regulate us and bail
us back to a growing economy
president donald trump created the
greatest economy in american history
[Applause]
it's amazing to think in the midst of a
global pandemic
joe biden actually wants to raise taxes
by four trillion dollars
[Music]
now president trump he cut taxes across
the board for working families and
businesses largely
we roll back more federal red tape than
any administration in history
we fought for free and fair trade
unleashed american energy
and in just three short years businesses
large and small
created more than seven million good
paying
jobs including 88 000 jobs
right here in the hoosier state
amazing
in those first three years unemployment
reached a 50-year low
and wages rose at their fastest pace
than any time in the last 10 years and
what means the most to the president of
me
is wages rose most rapidly for
hard-working
blue-collar americans the forgotten men
and women
of america were forgotten no more
[Applause]
true
and when it comes to jobs here in the
hoosier state you know
i always used to tell people in indiana
we do two things well
we make things and we grow things
and we sell them not only around the
country but we sell it all over the
world don't we
so when it comes to trade trade means
jobs in indiana
you all deserve to know when we took
office
half of our international trade deficit
was with communist china
and joe biden never lifted a finger to
do anything about it
in fact joe biden has been a cheerleader
for communist china all along the way he
said the rise of china was a
a positive development and he dismissed
the notion that china was even a
competitor of the united states
but under president donald trump we put
china on notice
we said the era of economic surrender is
over we impose tariffs on
china and will keep standing strong
until they open
up their markers to what we make and
what we grow
and closer to home we all remember nafta
right in the 25 years after nafta was
signed
here in indiana and around the heartland
we literally saw entire communities
shuddered 60 000
factories were closed and many of those
jobs were moved south of the border
and overseas and again
joe biden and the democrats always
talked a lot about what was wrong with
nafta but they never did a thing to
change it
but the man who wrote the art of the
deal he got america
a better deal nafta is gone
and the usmca is here to stay
[Applause]
and when it comes to energy joe biden
and the radical left want to crush
american energy
and american jobs under a two trillion
dollar version of the green new deal
you know the president had to remind him
at the last presidential debate that he
supported the green new deal
and he just might remind him again
tonight
i mean i mean the green new deal on on
their campaign
website is essentially the same as aoc's
green new deal
and that's according to usa today the
three new deal
actually would require the retrofitting
of four million
business buildings 2 million homes
would raise the cost of electricity for
every home and business in indiana
and in america president trump
he's been a champion for american energy
we ended
the war on coal expanded energy
production
all over america and we're now a net
exporter of energy for the first time in
70 years
we're energy independent
you know when joe biden was vice
president
america actually lost 200 000
manufacturing jobs
and the president back then said they
were never coming back
you know i got to tell you i don't take
out here in indiana i mean
these people on the east coast and the
left coast like to call this part of the
country back in those days the rust belt
remember and there was a lot of
there was a lot of rust on the belt
buckle when they were running things
remember remember president obama four
years ago
when he talked about those 200 000
manufacturing jobs were gone
he said they were gone for good he said
what magic wand do you have
well we didn't need a magic wand we just
needed president donald trump in the
white house
500 000 manufacturing
jobs in the first three years including
nearly 10
000 right here in the hoosier state
[Applause]
and i got to tell you that that's a
credit to hard-working hoosiers
it's a credit to this president and his
policies our allies in the congress
support it
but i also want to say it's also a
credit to a governor
who believes in indiana manufacturing
and has fought
for hoosier jobs join me in thanking
governor eric holcomb for putting
hoosier workers first
[Laughter]
so the choice could not be more clear
even when it comes to health care
now you all remember the disaster of
obamacare right
remember all the lies of obamacare they
said if
if you like your doctor you can keep
them wasn't true
they said if you like your health
insurance you can keep it
that wasn't true either they said health
insurance premiums would go down
when we took office health insurance
premiums
had doubled since obamacare became law
now joe biden and kamala harris they got
a plan that
that exports socialized medicine from
bernie sanders medicare for all plan
they call it a public option to put
right in the middle of obamacare and
it'll set our nation on an inexorable
path
to socialized medicine but under
president donald trump
we got rid of the individual mandate and
we've been fighting to lower the cost of
health insurance
without growing the size of government
we have lowered the cost of prescription
drugs
we passed right to try and we're going
to improve the greatest health care
system
in the world with free market
principles and america will never be
a socialist country
[Applause]
we've been improving health care in this
country and we're going to keep
improving it and i got to give one more
credit where credit's due folks
there's a doctor who became a
congressman
he represents a district down near
evansville indiana but he is one of the
leading
voices on free market health care reform
that respects
the doctor patient relationship in
america would you join me in thanking
indiana
congressman larry bushon thank you doc
we got a doc in the house
[Applause]
my fellow hoosiers we have a choice to
make on this economy
i really believe it's a choice between a
trump recovery and a biden depression
there was a recent study that just came
out that said joe biden's economic
policies
would cause america to lose five million
jobs
and it would cost the average family
household income six thousand five
hundred dollars a year
so the question i i want you to ask your
family members and your neighbors and
your coworkers and friends in the next
12 days is this
who do you really think is going to
bring this economy all the way back
a career politician who spent 47 years
in washington dc
raising taxes growing government waving
a white flag of economic surrender
on trade or a proven job
creator who will keep cutting taxes
fighting for american jobs and workers
for our families for our jobs for the
great
american comeback we need four more
years
of president donald trump in the white
house
that's what we need so we stood
for our national security we've stood
for
prosperity fought for american jobs
american energy and american workers and
every single day president donald trump
has stood for the rule of law as i stand
here today
our president has confirmed more than
230
federal judges and they are all
principled conservatives who will uphold
the freedom of religion
the freedom of speech and the second
amendment right to keep and bear
arms
incredible last month we paused as a
nation rightly to honor the life and
service of the late justice ruth vader
ginsburg
but when the memorials were over
president trump fulfilled his duty under
the constitution
[Applause]
and he nominated a principled
brilliant conservative hoosier
woman to the supreme court of the united
states of america judge amy coney
barrett
isn't she great
indiana is proud of judge amy coney
barrett
what an amazing person now the president
and i did call on the democrats
to give judge barrett a respectful and
dignified confirmation this time around
but we uh we have reason to be concerned
as you might remember a couple years ago
when she was being confirmed to the
court of appeals
ranking democrat on the judiciary
committee
actually said she was concerned
because judge barrett's catholic faith
she actually said quote the dogma
lives loudly within you
and hollywood elites have already been
criticizing judge barrett's faith
and her convictions
well i got news for the democrats and
their friends in hollywood
that dogma lives loudly in me
that dogma lives loudly in you
and the right to live and work and
worship
according to the dictates of our faith
lives loudly in the constitution of the
united states of america now the
senate's going to vote
this monday they got her out of
committee today
and after they discharged their duty to
advise and consent
i'll make a prediction indiana's
judge amy coney barrett
is going to become america's justice amy
coney barrett
we're going to fill that seat
now hoosiers deserve to know one more
thing about the supreme court
after 150 years with nine
judges on the supreme court
leading democrats in washington d.c are
talking about packing the court
[Music]
they're talking about adding seats to
the supreme court
so they can appoint activist liberal
judges to enact their
liberal agenda from the bench
[Applause]
and joe biden's been all over the map on
this
first he said he wasn't going to answer
then he said he was going to answer it
after judge barrett was confirmed next
week
now he just told a television interview
that he's going to answer the question
after the election
[Music]
he called it a live ball
come on man
the american people deserve a straight
answer joe
when you're running for the highest
office in the land we got to know if
you're going to respect the highest
court in the land
[Applause]
[Music]
you know i mean we all know what's going
on here right
i mean i was born in the morning but not
yesterday morning
and joe biden and kamala harris are
going to pack the court
with liberal activist judges to advance
their left
wing agenda if they win the election
but we're not gonna let it happen we're
gonna re-elect
president donald trump for four more
years and protect an independent
judiciary for generations to come
[Applause]
[Music]
so we stood for the rule of law
appointed judges at every level
and will stand for that independent
judiciary
and president donald trump has stood
every day
with the men and women who serve on the
thin blue line
of law enforcement
and we always will
you know during my during my years as a
congressman from this state and as your
governor
i saw up close the incredible
caliber of the men and women of law
enforcement
city police officers county sheriffs
our great indiana state police and as
i've traveled around this country
i can tell you the men and women who
serve in law enforcement
across the state and nation are some of
the best people in this country
and they deserve the respect of every
american
every day
let's hear it for our law enforcement
officers who are here
[Applause]
now the president and i will always
support the right of peaceful protest
it's enshrined in our constitution
but rioting and looting is not peaceful
protest
[Applause]
burning businesses is not free speech
now for months all joe biden talked
about all summer long was peaceful
protests remember
as americans literally watched
businesses
in cities around the country burned to
the ground
i'll never forget being in minneapolis
just couple short weeks ago with a
wonderful african-american business
owner
named flora westbrook
she started a little salon in
minneapolis 35 years ago
it really became a center of the
community
but she told me about the night just a
couple nights after the killing of
george floyd
how she watched the protesters come
closer and closer and closer
to her little salon until they burned it
to the ground
well i'm proud to report to you that
floor is getting a lot of support we're
going to rebuild that salon
the truth is her story is one of
hundreds and hundreds of stories
impacting families of every race and
creed and color in major cities around
the country
and the truth is joe biden's policies
i believe the policies that he doubled
down on
are contributing to the atmosphere of
violence in our cities
you know when you start to withdraw
support
or even condemn those who support
people that protect and serve you only
emboldened those
who would do harm to our families and
our communities
now joe biden explains all of it by
saying
that he believes america is quote
systemically racist
and he and kamala harris say all the
time that they think police in this
country have a quote
implicit bias against minorities
when joe biden was asked if he cut
funding to law enforcement he said
yes absolutely
but under president donald trump i'll
make your promise
we're not going to defund the police
not now not ever
we're going to back the blue and we're
going to back the blue for four more
years
now you and i you and i know
what the president knows and that is we
we don't have to choose between
supporting law enforcement
and supporting our african-american
neighbors and families and other
minorities and families in our major
cities
we've done both the last three and a
half years and we'll keep doing both for
four more years
under this administration we've we've
provided record funding for law
enforcement four thousand new police
officers on the street
this summer when violence was impacting
our cities we launched operation legend
named after
a four year little boy who was killed in
his bed by violence
and we've already arrested 3 000 violent
offenders
in cities across the country
but at the same time at the same time
the last three and a half years i
couldn't be more proud to be
vice president in an administration that
saw the lowest unemployment ever
recorded for african americans
we have fought for school choice for
every family
in every city in america
we created 8 000 opportunity zones we
passed criminal justice reform
and this president signed the largest
investment in historically black
colleges and universities ever
[Applause]
we're going to stand with law
enforcement we're going to stand with
our minority communities
and we're going to have law and order in
every city
in every state for every american of
every race and creed
and color so help us god
[Applause]
and finally when it comes to values
when joe biden was vice president
we saw a steady assault on the religious
freedom
of americans of every faith we did
conscience rights of doctors and nurses
and religious charities were compromised
and when joe biden was vice president
their administration actually hauled the
little sisters of the poor
into federal court to force them
to compromise their faith to live under
the mandates of obamacare
[Music]
president donald trump we restored the
conscience rights
of doctors and nurses and teachers and
religious charities
and president trump ended the assault on
the little sisters of the poor
and the supreme court made it permanent
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and finally where joe biden and kamala
harris
support taxpayer funding of abortion
all the way up to the moment of birth
and are calling for record
increases in funding to the largest
abortion provider
in america i couldn't be more proud
to be vice president to the most
pro-life
president in american history
[Applause]
oh
in our first month in office this
president reinstated the mexico city
policy to make sure taxpayer dollars
would never provide or promote abortion
and president trump signed a bill that
allowed states
across america to defund planned
parenthood
we have stood for the unborn and we will
stand for the right
to life for four more years
so in our first three years
if you're taking notes you rebuild our
military revive the economy we stood for
law
and order and liberties in life
and let me say none of that would have
been possible without the strong and
consistent support
of indiana's delegation to the united
states
congress so hoosiers right after you
reelect president donald trump
for four more years we need to send
congressman jim banks
congressman larry bouchon
back to a new republican majority
in the house of representatives and
retire
nancy pelosi once and for all
[Laughter]
i want steve scalise leading a
republican majority
in the congress
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i mean really when you look at what we
were able to accomplish when we had a
republican house
and a republican senate all the progress
we made as a nation
in those first three years there's only
one way you can describe it
in three short years
we made america great again
we did
[Laughter]
and then 2020 arrived and the
coronavirus struck from
china but i'm here to tell you
before the first documented case of
community spread in the united states
president trump did what no american
president had ever done in our history
he suspended all travel from china
the second largest economy in the world
true
now now joe biden called that xenophobic
remember he actually said it was
hysterical
he wrote in a major newspaper that
closing down travel from any country
would make things worse
but i can tell you firsthand
having led the white house coronavirus
task force for the last eight months
[Applause]
president donald trump's decision to
suspend all travel from china
saved untold american lives and it
bought us
invaluable time to stand up the greatest
national mobilization
since world war ii
true
we reinvented testing we began before
the month of february was out to develop
new medicines to begin the process of
developing a vaccine
we saw to the manufacturer including
here in indiana
of billions of medical supplies for our
incredible doctors and nurses
and health care workers and first
responders and before the end of this
year
we are going to have the first safe and
effective coronavirus vaccine with tens
of millions of doses for the american
people
[Applause]
that's what leadership looks like
now we have a ways to go and we all have
a role to play but i promise you
every step of the way we're going to
keep making sure that our doctors and
nurses and hospitals have the supplies
and the medicines
and the resources to give any hoosier
that's impacted by this pandemic the
level of care that we'd want a member of
our family to have
we're going to keep working to slow the
spread to protect the vulnerable
to save lives and where joe biden is
talking about shutting down our economy
we're opening up america again mean
after losing 22 million jobs at the
height of this pandemic it's amazing
we've already seen 11 and a half million
americans go back to work in just
five months including almost 300
000 people right here in the hoosier
state
we're working every day to open up
america again and we are opening up
america's schools
and i'm proud to report to you mrs pence
is already back
teaching in a classroom in that little
christian school
near washington d.c
[Laughter]
really is remarkable to think about all
that we accomplished
men and women we gather here today
because we've just passed through a time
of testing
but in 12 days we're coming to a time
for choosing
the choice in this election has never
been clearer
but the stakes have never been higher i
mean when you look at their agenda
of higher taxes open borders
socialized medicine abortion on demand
a green new deal defunding the police
and packing the courts
clear joe biden would be nothing more
than a trojan horse for the radical left
now joe biden said uh at their
convention that democracy is on the
ballot
well i think our economic recovery is on
the back
i think law and order are on the back
but i also believe there are things much
more foundational
and fundamental to who we are that are
on the ballot as well
you know in this election i think it's
not just whether america is going to end
up
more conservative or more liberal
more republican or more democrat more
red or more blue i think the choice in
this election is whether america remains
america
it's whether we're going to chart a
course based on our highest ideals
of freedom and patriotism
of liberties of faith and family
or whether we're going to let joe biden
kamala harris the democratic party take
us down a pathway
charted by the radical left to socialism
and american decline so let me say for
our freedom
for all the ideals that have always made
america great
my fellow hoosiers we have to decide
right here and
right now that joe biden will never
be president of the united states we're
going to re-elect
president donald trump for four more
years
it's about what we've done
it's about the choice and it's about
what we have yet to do
you know over the next four years as the
president said
we will distribute the vaccine and
defeat the china virus
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might and ensure peace through
strength
we will make indiana and america the
manufacturing
superpower of the world and end our
reliance on
[Music]
[Applause]
china
[Applause]
we'll uphold religious liberty freedom
of speech
the right to keep and bear arms we'll
hire more police
we'll ban sanctuary cities
and we will stop the indoctrination
of our students and restore patriotic
education to our schools
[Applause]
and as president trump said at mount
rushmore
we'll teach our kids to love our country
honor our history and always respect our
great
american flag
[Music]
folks i got to tell you it's uh it's
great to be back home again
it really is and i want to thank you
thank you for coming out today but
thank you for the honor of serving as
your vice president it's the greatest
honor of my life
[Laughter]
i can tell all of you
karen and i know that uh everything in
our life is a result of
the grace of god the support of my
family and the confidence of the people
of indiana and we will never let you
down
thank you so much
you know it's hard for me to believe
that four years have passed
it's hard for me to believe that
four years have passed since the day i
got the phone call to join this national
ticket
i'll never forget it like all of you in
this room
i saw in our candidate four years ago a
man who had the leadership
qualities who had the vision who had the
agenda to make america great
we got tipped off that the phone call
was going to come in at the governor's
residence
it was about 11 o'clock at night karen
and i had prayed all the way through it
we knew we were going to say yes in a
heartbeat
and then the phone rang and i picked up
the phone
and i heard that familiar voice over the
phone lines
and he said mike it's going to be great
and you know what it's been great every
single day
and we're gonna make it greater for four
more years
[Laughter]
you know before i got that phone call
the president and i didn't even know
each other that well
i mean some people think we're a little
bit different
but i can tell you we've become very
close friends i've served alongside this
man every day and
i'm going to tell my fellow hoosiers
from my heart i've seen him when the
bright lights are off
there's no cameras around and i can tell
you first hand
against unrelenting
opposition by the democrats
and their allies in the national media
there's never been a day gone by
that this president hasn't gotten up and
fought to keep the promises that he made
to the people of
indiana now it's our turn to fight for
him
it's on indiana
this is it
okay so i got a couple things i got to
ask you to do before i get back on that
airplane you all have made it possible
for me to ride
[Music]
in the next 12 days first and foremost
number one you need to
vote indiana vote to re-elect
president donald trump to the white
house
early voting has already started karen
and i are going to be turning in our
ballots tomorrow down in indianapolis
you can get it done too you just go down
to memorial coliseum
they're open 8 to 4 30 every day
just go down and remember friends don't
let friends vote
alone bring a family member bring a
neighbor
bring a co-worker and vote to re-elect
president trump vote to re-elect
governor holcomb
vote to re-elect congressman banks
go republican
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so number one after you vote with a
friend
number two i want you to go tell
somebody
what you heard here today i want to go
i want you to go tell somebody why you
came here
today i see the determination on your
faces
i know you you already know the
difference this president's leadership
has made
the difference our allies in the
congress have made
coming alongside his agenda for a
stronger more prosperous america
so go tell somebody
talk to people that worship and at work
and far beyond the boundaries of indiana
reach out to neighbors and friends send
out an email pick up the phone
tweet if you must
but let people know why you so
passionately support this president
and this team and this agenda and all we
can do for four more years
and finally lastly i i would tell you
that if you're
inclined to bow the head and bend the
knee over the next
12 days i'd encourage you to do that too
you know
i know pastor hawks got us off on the
right foot
at this rally the little girl
turned in a question during that vice
presidential debate she
talked about how she turned on the tv it
just seems like
people were more divided and
ever before
but i tried to tell her then and i
believe in my heart
after traveling all across this country
on this journey that indiana set me on
so many years ago
i'll always believe that there's there's
more that unites
these united states of america than
could ever divide us and chief among
those things is faith
this is a nation of faith
and so i encourage you
in this momentous time in the midst of a
global pandemic as our economy and our
america's getting back on our feet
beginning to move forward facing such a
dramatic choice i just encourage you to
encourage you to pray pray with
confidence though
in those ancient words that americans
have clung to through
much more challenging times than we
could even imagine
that if his people who are called by his
name will humble themselves
and pray and turn he'll do like he's
always done
in the long and storied history of this
nation
he'll hear from heaven and he'll heal
this land
this one nation under god
indivisible with liberty and justice
for all so pray for america
pray for all of the american people
it'll make a difference
and i just and i just know in my heart
if all of us do all that we need to do
in every hour that remains between now
and the close of poles
we're going to have a great victory all
across indiana and all across america
we're going to make indiana and america
stronger than ever before we're going to
make indiana
and america more prosperous than you
could possibly imagine
we're going to make indiana and america
more united
than ever before
[Applause]
and the congressman jim banks
congressman larry bushon
and steve scalise back in a new
republican majority
on capitol hill with governor
eric holcomb back in the state house
with president donald trump back in the
white house for four more years and with
god's help
we will make america great again
again thank you very much
indiana god bless you
and god bless america let's go get it
[Music]
done
[Music]
over new
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
to dance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
he was a singer
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
now i'm
[Music]
so many times it happens too fast
don't lose your grip on the dreams of
the past
you must fight just to keep them alive
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
rising up straight to the top
now i'm not gonna stop
[Music]
those survivors
oh
hello
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
uh